[Music]
well I apologize for what I'm about to
do to you I apologize if I'm about to do
all of you but and I like to quote I
hope maybe he's listening to I like to
coach farage
you gotta let Tim pool cook
s
[Music]
[Applause]
are you a Green Day fan
I mean he's definitely ripping off Green
Day here
but
also these lyrics this everything about
this so now he's doing a show as like
now he's cheaping out on the music
videos you made all that money Tim what
happened
somebody who couldn't get the drummer
from The Offspring back in for another
video shoot
[Music]
me
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so he's singing a bad Green Day rip-off
song by the way not even good Arab Green
Day this is like America idiot American
Idiot Green Day and he's singing about
all these MSM oh he's the worst God he's
such an uninspired beanie wearing
childlike douche
uh
go ahead no no
no go ahead he should be stuffed in a
locker and it should be sealed like a
sarcophagus I like that uh Frozen uh yes
uh Sriracha in the locals chat the slap
so [ __ ] hard
for me let me tell you something Suraj
you do not live far enough away from us
for you to be saying things like that do
you understand me you live with siraj
over we are we are a we are a car drive
away bud
do you hear me
well there goes the rumble partnership I
don't care you've been a part [ __ ]
the only part is just in my fist is
around his face if he ever defends his
music again if he ever defends Tim
Paul's music [ __ ] like you know what
[ __ ] locals Rumble exclusivity or no
exclusivity I'm firing seven six twos
[Laughter]
in the local tattoo
you said uh yes he's at the local show
oh it's so funny
okay what's he
what are you doing man what are you
doing man
may I yeah he's uh uh being a okay you
listen here's the thing man I'm an
American
okay that's nice I wish we said we said
too many times
do you want to be an American
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
[Laughter]
I wish I was the minority I wish they
would turn a hose on me oh Suraj is
rocking out in the permanent chat he's
not in the show in the show locals okay
that's why I didn't see him move to the
show One dummy
[Music]
I think that's his new producer okay
why does this new producer look just
like his old producer oh you know what
I've actually been hanging out in the 24
hour chat too oh that's so funny so wait
a second hold on hold on hold on also
show has frozen then because that's
where he saw it this is so funny and I'm
hanging out in the [ __ ] show chat
all right so this is so this here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to keep
playing this song because it's very
catchy and then I'm gonna just rename
the to 24 7 Premium hangout slash live
chat boom
no no name it no homers Club oh okay
edit
you remember guys we can't have one yeah
no homers club we should name it the no
we should name it the no sirages Club
but we're allowed to have one
[Music]
next
[Music]
how can I see anything
oh my God
it's also like I could have found
somebody on Fiverr to make me a better
music video right like it's a shitty
music video on top of everything else
here's what I don't care this is what I
don't understand he [ __ ] he made a
[ __ ] whole video that he spent
obviously some money to make right and
then he was like guys get me to the top
of iTunes and then he got up to number
two and he [ __ ] fell back down and he
pocketed all the money and he didn't
even make a follow-up video this was
always a quick cash grab so now he's
just gonna crank out some cheat videos
to be like oh yeah I did my work
you guys aren't looking at the big
picture okay what's the big picture
album there's an album coming
oh yeah oh it's music videos
yeah that makes sense yeah there is
there is an album coming oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
he's not a good singer why does he think
he's a good snow but he's really like
he's really impressed with himself how
no I'm not
it's like when James Robert Clark talks
about literally anything
and you're like how are you so confident
[Music]
[Applause]
great lyrics by the way bro this is so
[ __ ] bad it's very bad
many many people look in my butt and I
feel like poop all the time and for the
record I've had people I don't like that
have done good comedy
have done well comedy but yeah I have
had people that have done well acting
good job well music
well liquor
um
I you and I have always been willing to
begrudgingly admit things sometimes like
we've always been willing to admit that
Gavin can be funny one of the funniest
people on the planet
like them
um and then like I've even said Tim
Dylan at times could be funny
um there's there's people in music I
don't like movies Kevin Spacey's good
actor just also you know may or may not
write kids
um and then have his Witnesses murdered
so it's like I
I can see through not liking you Tim
because I know what you're thinking
you're gonna see these clips and be like
oh these guys are always bashing me is
these are just [ __ ] [ __ ] haters
dude but it's not because there's people
I don't like that occasionally how many
times have we watched a Gavin clip and
we're literally yelling about him the
whole time but he'll say one thing and
we'll both be like okay that was [ __ ] it
that was pretty good Tim I've never once
went oh [ __ ] okay Tim that was pretty
good man
uh let's see here uh fisted sister sent
five dollar tip five bucks towards the
temple album listening party show do it
do it do it oh my God
oh my God this is a great Point uh
Samurai cicada said he finally did what
he wanted to do 15 years ago but it
never evolved with the times
this would be like me wanting to make
like the album I wanted to make in high
school I mean you're like wait a minute
you're gonna crank out 12 pop punk songs
39 I don't think that's gonna be a good
album dude
finally released that new metal album
Mercy yes new metal or like Ska you know
and you're like whoa it's it's too
[ __ ] late man what are you doing so
Twisted Fister just did make a good
point how much would you guys take to do
a listening party for this album
whenever it comes out how much would we
ask for
I mean it would have to be how many uh
do you know how many tracks were on it
12 tracks I don't know man we would have
we I would really because that's that's
that I mean that's literally investing
our free time
forget about free time it's asking me to
listen to it and talk okay so you have
to listen to an entire [ __ ] 10 pool
album I don't know man
I will talk about when it comes out
and what we're supposed to be when is it
drops when does it drops when does it
drop
when does it drop yeah it's an album
when does it drop
do we know when it when you when it hits
the streets so far there's only two
singles okay
[Music]
I tell you what you know what Marsh I'm
with you because there's a lot of people
watching our Rumble and a lot of people
that have made the jump over on patreon
we'll do it
for these just on level just on locals
oh just literally a hundred percent on
on locals premium locals when it drops
how's that that sounds like fair but you
have you guys got to start signing up
then and show us you want it
because honestly I don't want to do this
I don't want to do this either
uh somebody has a very good question for
ten dollars that's Justin just in time
uh who's worse Tim pool music or
Crowders covers Crowders covers in my
opinion
um and I could explain why
but you go ahead what do you think
I hate to say this
it's Tim Poole's music is worse yes
remarkably worse is is Crowder
almost more cringe and like borderline
embarrassing and bad at comedy yes but
at least his shit's intended to be
comedy Tim's trying to be serious and
he's trying to be sexy so yeah it's way
worse like Crowder just likes to find an
excuse to dress up in wigs because he
doesn't want to let his wife down and
tell her he's gay like Tim Poole really
thinks he's a [ __ ] leading man like
he thinks he's a [ __ ] thinks he's
[ __ ] Steven Tyler over here this
little Beanie wearing so now Tim pulls
worse we will do a premiums record
release party for the locals what are we
at right now we're we're a good amount
of subscribers too so
um I think that would that would be
something that I'll take the bullet for
that
[Music]
hey you know what I was just thinking
Mars just to make you feel even worse
about when we do this you know he's
going to have an acoustic love song
right you know 100 people gotta have a
ballot every good album's got a ballot
because you know why
Every Rose Has Its Thorn
dude he is [ __ ] and I won't say this
every podcaster has its soft side
somebody asked what's worse like you
know Crowder or Tim pool yeah I'll tell
you who's the most offensive person in
its entire equation it's not even Temple
it's all the people who are lying to
Temple to keep their jobs to keep them
happy to gas them up everybody that's
[ __ ] Tim Poole is supposed to be a
delusional egotistical [ __ ]
the fact that he's got all these people
around him going yeah man that sounds
great
but I don't even think you need to do
any more takes well you could argue that
with Crowder's covers too he has been
that's why they're they're equal
standing with me because Crowder has
people around that are afraid it gets
fired that he also makes signs ndas you
know so for me the only reason I say
Crowder's worse is and I'm not giving
Tim pull credit but even though his [ __ ]
sucks at least he's trying to do
something original not doing just a
Weird Al parody cover that's for me
that's the reason they're both doing me
already [ __ ] sucks
that's the reason I I think that uh that
Crowder is worse
do can we do a poll in this thing oh no
you got to reset the whole chat huh to
do a poll yeah I don't think so is it
hold on let me try something here
um I want to see because if I could do
this I know this would be just another
game changer but publication setting
it'd be nice to have a poll add content
add pull oh yes I can then we just have
to refresh option one we'll just have to
ask him yeah who's where we'll let we'll
let the locals we'll let the uh the
non-pores vote on it okay uh Crowder
Tim Poole just [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
turning to Starship Troopers yeah local
membership equal citizenship
well it's also the rumble Fridays it's
our it's our fun day anyway um anyway uh
let's see here publish okay so if you
are in currently in the chat right now
there is a poll who's worse Crowder or
Tim pool you may vote just refresh all
you have to do is hit refresh and the
poll should come up I'm can I vote
I can I voted for mine merch you could
vote for yours
okay I gotta just refresh yep
I did oh there it is yeah okay again
it's right under the picture so [ __ ]
cool I love this [ __ ] on local this is
awesome like on the Fly I could do this
I saw the option for poles yeah I just
haven't [ __ ] with them in the chat
yeah I did my first live locals chat
last night for nightwave I mean it was a
ghost town but I'm doing it to be a team
player and uh I was like oh poles I just
didn't know you could go in and edit it
and just add one which is cool I love
that there's two people that the first
two people that voted were me and merch
and it split 50 50. nice 26 people
voting we are currently at Tim pool with
61
oh he's way more egregious bad comedy is
not as offensive as um bad music in my
opinion fair enough that's fair enough
because it's again it's the
pretentiousness of it it's like the you
know and and the honestly like you said
like oh you know at least Tim's trying
to do something original at least when
[ __ ] you know Crowder rips off Green
Day he's just blatantly ripping off
Green Day and doing a parody song This
Guy's trying to pass Green Day off as
his own [ __ ] you should be [ __ ] put
in jail for this I hope he gets sued I
hope [ __ ] I hope uh what's his face
Susan what's the what's that guy's name
with the [ __ ] eye makeup I hope we
can Billy Joe Armstrong yeah what the
[ __ ] eye makeup
with the eyes a fake British accent the
guy from the guy from Bakersfield with
the fake shitty British accent he's from
[ __ ] Southern California and he's
saying log dish foreign
oh [ __ ] that's so hilarious Billy Joe
always sounded like he was about to
vomit like well you got me a time
that he's like he was about to throw up
and he also had a stuffy nose all right
we have 100
votes in and we're at Temple 60 wow
Temple is [ __ ] just running away with
this because he's awful
yeah like I I hate Crowder right right I
don't want Crowder thrown in prison I
want Temple thrown in a CIA black State
Prison got it fair enough this compound
is basically okay the good part wait
till you get to the good part of this
video got it
[Music]
can I ask a question sure why would you
do it because he said drone strike and
then why would you do a drone strike
from a manned F-16
doesn't even make any sense well no
nothing else makes sense he's using an
Ops using OBS overlay for his video I
mean I don't know
hey nice there it is no
here it is no Suraj and the locals chat
said Tim Poole can still cook
I wish yeah yeah yeah I wish it was I
wish it was right I wish I wish it was
ryzen
by the way subscribe to the Habibi Bros
habibros [ __ ] rules
[Music]
so bad it's so [ __ ] bad spice rice
wait why is Alex Jones so sassy why is
he such a fantastic [ __ ]
they're turning the freaking frogs gay
you have to watch this as a family Royce
come on let's go
69 nice for Tim pool nice
you cancel a vote and change the votes
and that's the other thing about this
it's gonna suck because now for sure the
numbers are going to be going the other
way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the face filter thing is so cringe
anyway but like who did the who helped
them make this video [ __ ] Kyle
Dunnigan with this [ __ ] hack
oh my God
he just used Wombo
[Music]
yeah somebody's calling it Bare Naked
Green Day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
taito in the [ __ ] local chat this is
worse for Alex in his recent court
decision
[Laughter]
for this so [ __ ] I thought you were
joking he used Wambo it's in the no I
wasn't it's in the description he used
Wambo
just use an app
yeah yeah that's because you couldn't
afford Jib Jab he can afford it
[Applause]
[Music]
is just the [ __ ] absolute worst thing
to happen the podcasting to music
uh to hats
it's all right surprise says bare naked
beanies yeah
make it right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish somebody would have told me when
I was playing guitar five hours a
[ __ ] day that really the the path to
success in music was food buckets
uh
in the rumble chat donated says I'm
giving my money to test something for my
live stream in OBS by the way Tim pool
is the John Lennon of Our Generation
[Music]
well yeah oh yeah he should
we all have the same joke we all have
the same joke I sure hope so
does anyone have a copy of Catcher in
the Rye I can read
because it's conspiracy theory of
reference nice I like that good movie
good Mel Gibson movie
[ __ ] Christ this has just been
he just he He Is We he really thinks
he's like [ __ ]
he fit this this [ __ ] [ __ ] really
fancies himself a [ __ ]
singer-songwriter the [ __ ] balls on
him